strengthening industry in the European
Union will be the focus as ministers
responsible for improving the e use
competitiveness meet in Brussels The
ministers will debate the challenges to
industrial competitiveness ways to
ensure that all EU policies impact
positively on industry and boosting
management and monitoring of major
reforms industries considered a central
pillar for building sustainable economic
growth in Europe the sector is a key
part of the e use 20 20 strategy for
growth and jobs which comes under the
microscope when the minister's debate a
midterm review of the plan they look at
how to better align the strategy to
support industry and help to achieve a
well-integrated EU internal market
ministers will also look at reforms and
resources that favour innovation and
research which are evolving into an
important source of growth and
employment they'll exchange views on
progress made on the development of a
European research area which would
reinforce standards of excellence in
research and so boost Europe's global
competitiveness
you